it goes without saying that the scp
foundation archives are filled with some
terrifying monsters
even the deadliest creatures can in
theory be defeated or at least soundly
avoided
after all they're just flesh and blood
or in some cases
metal or concrete but what if reality as
you know it one day just
broke or worse you were transported to a
reality so frightening and alien to our
own
that death seemed like the only escape
but you couldn't even give yourself that
this brings us to today's topic the
terrifying alternate reality
of scp-3001 the foundation is no
stranger to freaky alternate dimensions
but what was experienced by joint lead
researcher dr robert scranton at site
120
is a truly unique nightmare co-managed
by his wife dr
anna lang site 120 is a facility largely
designated for research into scps with
dangerous reality warping capabilities
in order to mitigate future containment
breaches reality warpers are among some
of the more perplexing and dangerous
scps
from the pocket dimension creating
scp-106
to the scp creating dr wondertainment
and
everything in between scranton and
lang's goal to further study such
entities was an admirable one
if a little over ambitious and on
january 2nd 2000
during the testing of a new technology
created by the foundation's leading
power couple
disaster finally struck scranton lang
had already been the brains behind one
of the foundation's most valuable tools
in the fight against reality bending
scps
the scranton reality anchors their
follow-up the lang scranton stabilizer
or lss likely would have been an even
more advanced variant of their earlier
invention
and should have been a huge success for
the team but things
didn't turn out that way dr scranton and
several other researchers were gathered
in reality lab a
performing routine tests on the lss
prototypes
while other technicians ran diagnostics
tests scranton stood at the control
panel the blinking red light above the
console confirming that everything was
going according to plan
but as anyone who's fallen victim to one
of the foundation's many anomalies will
tell you
just because you've done everything
correctly doesn't mean you're safe
scranton began operating the machine not
knowing that something was rumbling up
towards him from below
without warning a sudden unexpected
burst of seismic activity
rocked the entire base researchers
grabbed on to whatever was closest as
the world shook around them
in his panic dr scranton clung to the
lss control panel as the seismic blast
fried the circuits
and kicked it into overdrive there was a
blast of magnificent blinding light
and when the rumbling stopped not only
was the doctor gone
he had been erased from reality as we
know it the earthquake had caused a
deadly malfunction in the machine meant
to stabilize reality
and instead tore a rift in it dragging
the unfortunate doctor
and the control panel into oblivion
his wife dr lang and the many
researchers who idolized him were
devastated by his unexpected demise at
the hand of what should have been his
crowning achievement
the one silver lining was that this
reality ripping event had almost
definitely eliminated the doctor quickly
and painlessly
as far as the foundation and his loved
ones were concerned scranton's death had
been immediate and complete
a luxury afforded to few foundation
employees who die anomalous deaths
but sadly that isn't how dr scranton's
story
or the story of scp-3001
ends no this is where it all begins
how do we know all this in the hellish
new place where scranton had been
transported
the control panel from the lss that he'd
been clinging to for dear life had been
transported with him
and continued to record audio data from
this anomalous location
not that dr scranton realized it not at
first anyway
as far as he knew he'd suddenly been
transported into a pitch black location
no sights no sounds no sense
true nothingness at first the doctor was
confused
one second he was testing out his new
technology and the next he was quite
literally nowhere
in spite of his current situation the
doctor was still an intelligent and
rational man
he took a moment to compose himself
hoping that in time his eyes would
adjust to the new darkness around him
but that moment never came the darkness
remained perfectly absolute
much like the darkness in another
reality defying scp
the deadly endless staircase known as
scp-087
the dark seemed thick almost like you
could touch it
the doctor not wanting to give himself
to despair and die in this impossible
place
and with no other options seemingly
available began walking
either he'd find his way out or the
foundation would find him no need to
panic
it may have altered the doctor's
temperament if he knew that the
foundation
already assumed he was dead and that no
search party was going to come looking
for him
still logic dictates that if a person
walks for long enough they're bound to
find
something the problem scranton was about
to face was that scp-3001 doesn't run by
any kind of conventional logic
he walked and walked and walked but he
didn't seem to get any nearer to
or farther from anything but how could
he even know
after all in total darkness there aren't
any landmarks to assist in navigation
the doctor walked and paced and screamed
for days on end
but he made no progress he was alone in
an empty world
he had no choice though so he kept
walking
and walking and walking for 11 days
during that time he felt his hunger and
thirst grow
he was in terrible pain from a mix of
starvation and dehydration
but the release of death didn't seem to
come for him he was going to have to
learn the rules of this new place the
hard way
and it grimly dawned on dr scranton that
dying in this place
might not even be the worst possible
outcome he paced and repeated facts to
himself
hoping to ground himself in the moment
and avoid the panic that could so easily
set in
name robert scranton age 39
birthday september 19 1961 favorite
color blue
favorite song living on a prayer wife
anna little by little the word seemed to
turn to nonsense in his mouth as the
terror grew
just as he felt like he was about to
lose his mind he noticed something
a small oasis in the endless darkness of
scp-3001
the glowing red light on the lss control
panel
where had it come from and how was it
still recording
the doctor had no idea but he was
grateful for any kind of familiarity in
the strange darkness around him
perhaps the lss could be the key to
saving him or at least figuring out what
on earth was going on here
whatever the case there was no denying
that having the panel here was better
than nothing
at least when it was found if it was
ever found
then people would know what had happened
to him as the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously survive
dr scranton deduced that one didn't need
food or water to survive
continually in scp-3001 the location had
an anomalous effect on its inhabitants
as the days passed and turned to weeks
of wandering in the darkness
dr scranton further deduced that he was
no longer in his home dimension
this was an entirely separate pocket
dimension much like the one possessed by
scp-106
but featureless a perfect self-contained
void
now dimly illuminated by the red light
of the panel dr scranton
explored further into the void around
him he traveled for months on end
the pain of his deficiencies growing by
the day but found he was getting nowhere
all things considered he wasn't even
sure he was moving or whether reality
and darkness were swirling around him
like a thick liquid
rather than walking on a single flat
surface he was moving in all directions
across a three-dimensional plane
the space-time continuum appeared to be
entirely broken here
where movement is more defined by the
conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning
dr scranton knew that this place broke
every single one of cajell's laws of
reality parameters
and from his years working with a
plethora of reality warpers in site 120
he had a theory for why this pocket
dimension was so strange
it had an extraordinarily weak hume
field before we get back to dr
scranton's semi-living nightmare we need
a quick primer on hume theory and why
having a weak hume field is such a
problem
a hume is a unit of measurement for the
strength and amount of reality in a
given location or being
in an area with an incredibly low hume
field relative to our world
such as scp-3001 universe breaches and
anomalous incidents rise significantly
at the time of his being trapped there
scp-3001 had the lowest number of humes
in any recorded environment
making it a phenomenally anomalous zone
it was for this reason that starvation
and dehydration never took hold of him
despite causing him great pain
and the worst by far was yet to come dr
scranton wasn't trapped in this
dimension for weeks or even months
he was trapped in the darkness for years
and it took a nightmarish toll on his
body and mind
the small flashing red light on his lss
control panel became his only friend
and as the years drew on he would hold
entire conversations with his only
source of illumination
he knew that his days were numbered if
he didn't escape the dimension within
around three years the hume field would
defuse further
and he would be left in a truly horrific
state
but based on how little headway he'd
made in the time he'd been there
he didn't feel optimistic he kept
speaking into the recorder
if only to break the silence and prevent
him from going completely insane
but even that would only hold it off for
so long alone and talking to himself
endlessly in the darkness
dr scranton could feel his mind slipping
as the confines of the pocket dimension
constricted
and his body began to change the low
hume field slowly diffused his physical
matter
destroying the physical integrity of his
body but never being merciful enough to
actually let him
die in his haunting audio logs the
doctor described his hands as diffusing
and thinning out like spider webs
over time there was less and less of him
and what was left
wasn't entirely human as scranton's hume
level lowered to equalize with that of
scp-3001
the lines between his body and the lss
control console began
to blur in a twisted marriage of warp
flesh and machine
the lang scranton stabilizer was
anything but stable
before his mind and body became
something else entirely the doctor still
had the presence of mind to finally
realize how he'd come to be in this
terrible place
the lss had opened a wormhole known as a
class c
broken entry into a paradoxical pocket
dimension between layers of reality
and taken him through it he'd slip
through a crack in reality into
absolute darkness and now he was stuck
with a fate
far worse than death how do we know any
of this
much like the event in the first place
it's a total accident
testing superior reality bending
technology almost six years after the
disappearance caused the sudden return
of the missing lss to site-120s reality
labs
the only trace of dr scranton that it
brought back with it was the blood and
viscera that coded the console
much to the abject horror of his
still-grieving wife dr anna lang
to this day dr scranton formerly one of
the foundation's brightest minds
remains trapped in the nightmare of
scp-3001
his current condition whether the doctor
is still alive after 20 years of being
warped by the low hume field of 3001's
darkened confines
is still unknown but for the doctor's
own sake
we hope he's been dead for quite some
time because few things on earth
are as horrifying as the alternative
you